Speaker 1: Does MAGA care more about democracy
or gas prices? Or maybe more accurately,
does MAGA care more about democracy or the promise
of lower gas prices when the current gas prices
aren't even very high? A version of this question
is what Chauncey Vega asks in a very good new
commentary in Salon called Is America Ready To
Trade Democracy for Cheap Gas? That's fascism in
a nutshell. Americans understand rates, Chauncey,
that democracy is in dire peril. That doesn't mean
they believe in it or give a damn. I encourage
you to check out this piece written yesterday.
He references the New York Times headline,
which says Voters see democracy in peril,
but saving it isn't a priority. He writes, The
details are grim. Voters, quote, overwhelmingly
believe American democracy is under threat but
seem remarkably apathetic about that danger,
with relatively few calling it the nation's
most pressing problem. More than one third of
independent voters in the poll said they were
open to supporting candidates who reject the
legitimacy of the 2020 election because economic
concerns are more urgent. 71% agreed democracy was
at risk. Only 7% said it was the most important
problem in the country. So one of the important
things to consider is that for many of these MAGA
voters, it's the promise of lower gas prices,
which they're willing to trade for democracy,
for the will of the people, depending who is
in office. But when you look at gas prices, you
say they're not even really that high. They're
down like 30 something percent from the peak. And
for the average vehicle, even if they were to go
down another 30%, you're only talking about quite
literally a few dollars difference for every full
tank that couldn't really be worth trading for a
functioning democracy, could it? But it appears
that for many voters, indeed it is. And so we are
down to the very end here as it comes to the 2022
midterms. We're going to have results starting
Tuesday night, and I hope you'll be live with
me on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. The 2022
midterms may be just the beginning. In fact,
they almost certainly will be just the beginning.
We will probably learn in the 24 to 48 hours that
follow Tuesday's elections. If and how committed
are right wingers to democracy 2020 suggested? The
answer is not particularly committed, but we will
see very quickly are they doing this? If we won,
it was fair. But if we lost, it's rigged thing.
Are they going to do it again? And if they do,
it will be a sign that it is now just sop standard
operating procedure for these folks and that will
be yet another divot in the democracy that is left
at this point in time. I don't know that they do
care about democracy at this point anymore. I
think that at this point they just want to win
now. We also just want to win, but we want to win
by people realizing their ideas are a disaster.
We're not trying to win by just putting in office
people who got fewer votes. That is a critical,
fundamental difference. You might think the top
tax rate should be 38% and you might think it's
42 and I might think it's 43. And those are
reasonable differences that exist in reality.
But if one of us believes that actually if my
candidate gets fewer votes, we should figure out a
way to install them anyway. That is very different
than a disagreement about tax policy or foreign
policy or whatever the case may be. I. I hate
the fact that the answer to is America ready to
give up democracy because they have been convinced
cheaper gas is more ex-pat, more important. I am
afraid that the answer is indeed yes. And we will
know much more about that, what, 72 hours from now